did you in terms of the red lines that
you laid down
is military response an option for a
ransomware attack
and president putin had called you in
his press conference
an experienced person you famously told
him he didn't have a soul
do you now have a deeper understanding
of him after this meeting
thank you very much
[Laughter]
i don't think he understands how
questions work
it's wednesday or as cat likes to call
it blur blurred vodka why am i waking up
in a hedge day
i kid the temp and the landscapers who
found her
although she really should take better
care of herself
getting worse so here's a funny question
is it wrong to be against arson you'd
think greg that's a dumb question
but setting fire to things is bad very
bad
unless it's one of hunter's paintings
but we should all condemn arson correct
well not so fast hypothetical viewer i'm
having an imaginary conversation with
you haven't heard the story of daniel
elder a talented musical artist
specializing in left-wing religious
music
he made the horrible mistake of publicly
scolding arsonists
after a george floyd protest in his
hometown of nashville
it turned violent resulting in assaults
vandalism and the torching of a historic
courthouse
elder again a very liberal dude posted
this
quote enjoy burning it all down you
well-intentioned blind people
i'm done well it sounds like what i say
after i use the bathroom
susan then he deleted his instagram
account and then he was deleted himself
it began the next morning when the
online mob
caught wind of his offense how dare you
condemn violent lawlessness they seemed
to say
they spammed his facebook accusing him
of racism and of course being a white
supremacist piece of garbage
which according to statistics now makes
up 85 of the country
in fact you don't even need to be white
anymore to be a white supremacist
you could be a black conservative and if
you're asian it depends if you're
getting beaten up or trying to get into
yale
hell you could be a christmas tree worm
sorry holiday tree worm but all you need
is a pulse and a wacky desire
to not see your neighborhoods burn but
that's not what the story is really
about it's about
corporate cowardice we spend a lot of
time on cancel culture here
focusing on the mob's thirst for scalps
again my apologies to liz warren but the
real ire
should be directed at companies who when
faced with a mob
toss a scapegoat into their grubby
ghoulish hands
like pontius pilate handing jesus to the
romans i'm referring to gia
it originally stood for gregorian
institute of america
but now it stands for groveling idiotic
gia is the leading publishers of
contemporary catholic liturgic
liturgic music songs you might find on
the pope's playlist right after all that
death metal
i'm not going to pretend that i've ever
heard of this company so i'm not going
to say well i used to be a fan
but damn i'm no fan now gia is an
offense
to gregorian monks they should have
taken a vow of silence on this
but when faced with temporary online
backlash what did they do to one of
their composers
gia president alec harris and media
editor susan labar
contacted elder and demanded an apology
even after admitting he did nothing
wrong
but they were so spooked by losing money
over boycotts that these greedy
capitalists
actually wrote the gutless apology for
him here's a sample quote
over the weekend i made a post that was
insensitive and wrongly worded i deeply
apologize for the anger
offense and harm that this post caused
there is no justification
for my post so rather than try to offer
an excuse for what was done i offer a
promise for
what i will do going forward i commit to
making amends
to dialogue i continue i commit to
continue educating myself about
privilege and bias my work begins now
all that was missing him telling his
family that they're treating him very
well and to put the unmarked bills in a
gym bag
that was a kidnapping reference audience
elder said he wouldn't do their
sniveling vomitus apology
so did gia back him up against the
temporary braying mob
nope they chose the mob dropping him
like bill de blasio trying to hold a
groundhog
they immediately terminated the
relationship over his incendiary remarks
funny how his incendiary remarks are
actually worse than actual incendiary
actions
like arson are jokes about o.j simpson
actually
worse than what o.j simpson did well
only if jimmy kimmel is delivering them
i wonder what the angry white male has
to say
[Music]
we not sorry
not sorry
so the real story isn't about cancel
culture we talk about that a lot
so so much so my head hurts it's like
when cat does math
or meth it's about companies
who after benefiting from your work
abandoning you with the slightest
negative pressure
this is no small crime because in every
case in which a person is sacrificed to
the horde of torch toters
we assume this horde is large when it's
actually smaller than aoc's book
collection
it's the companies that are large but
their spines are as weak as weed was in
1992
fact is you only need a tiny minority to
destroy society
revolutions are not unleashed by the
masses the masses do it to themselves
when faced with an immovable minority
in this case four tweeters sitting home
alone with their ten cats
and zero friends they can bring a
company of thousands to its groveling
knees by scaring their cowardly execs
it's a microcosm of all the bloodiest
revolutions it's never tens of millions
but a handful of over-educated radicals
who get the population
cowering and they run right through them
like kova 19 through a cuomo run nursing
home
this this is the blueprint for
revolution and it's tearing through our
education system our government our
businesses
gia should be ashamed of themselves and
they should apologize
in fact i'm gonna do it for them we are
sorry we abandoned one of our artists
just to protect our bottom line
if jesus christ were asked about this
mess what do you think he would say
it wouldn't be sorry if my remarks upset
the pharisees
maybe we should have more money changers
in the temple he might say forgive them
father they know not what they do
and under his breath say what a bunch of
a-holes
[Applause]
welcome to nice guests
she's broke more ground than that
asteroid that killed the dinosaurs fox
business correspondent susan lee
he has a brain like einstein and
also his hair host of james i'll touch
your show
podcast james alcatra
he split more sides than a cheap friend
at applebee's comedian terrence k
williams
and she gets her cardio from falling
down the stairs fox news contributor
captain
so i read this story in reason it was
another great story by
robbie suave i don't know where he gets
the energy i hate him for that
but susan you claim to be an expert in
business
i claim yeah you claim you have yet to
show us any proof and
frankly it's disappointing but
i'm sorry because you were the color of
pepto-bismol
why do you think corporations are so
quick to give in to the mob when they i
mean they must know it's not a large mob
i did some homework for you oh cancel
culture because the last time i was here
i spoke to my mother afterwards because
she watched the show
and she hates it when i talk about her
on television but she lived through a
horrible
time in history called the cultural
revolution right
right and that was a time when you were
finger and point and tattletail
on people right to prove your own
virtuousness
exactly and this is exactly what's
happening once again does she did she
note that to you did she say oh my god
this doesn't look like a good thing is
happening well think about what happened
in history i mean
lives were destroyed right i look like
somebody that knows a lot about him
i know i know i of course i know about
the great leap forward in the millions
that's what it was called yes yes and
mao you have now chairman mao yeah not a
good guy
yeah but not a good time that's what
she's saying cancel culture is not good
like the cultural revolution that is
true so james you've you've been through
stuff like this and you're in the car
you own a comedy club
um this is kind of is this this is kind
of frightening that they would throw
this guy under the bus so quickly
yeah people seem to think now that if
you even say the wrong thing if you
think the wrong thing
then they have the right to destroy your
career destroy your property
destroy everything about you know delete
you and so here's a guy
who you know 50 years ago everyone was
saying oh you can't
you can't burn books but now now they're
saying oh but if you don't
if you criticize burning down
courthouses that's fine
don't burn books but burn courthouses
we're all cool with that and then if you
disagree with that
they're gonna they're gonna burn you
like you said and and you know to
susan's point
if you look at every fascist movement in
history it starts off with
socialism these things are called
national socialist movements or
you know mussolini's original party was
the socialist party yeah and that's what
you're seeing here and they don't
realize that somehow they're not being
taught curiosity they're being taught
they're being taught opinions rather
than facts which is how i make my living
by the way
you know uh i don't like them going
after books i don't like them going
after courthouses and if they ever go
after your luscious hair
i will be there on the friday they go
after that they just they do they're
going to come at you with some clippers
number three's i would imagine right
a curling iron maybe a curling iron i
don't know enough of me you know why are
you making fun of his hair
it's gorgeous terrence terrence k
uh gia behavior this is the thing that i
find so ironic
is the exact opposite of christ-like
behavior right you know
i'm bothered right now because i just
found out that i'm a white supremacist
so i'm really at lost words right now
because i'm against burning down
buildings i'm against black lives matter
burning down buildings
but to assume that it's racist to burn
down buildings
you are saying that only white people
own businesses and buildings
that's yep so that's racist but there
were a lot of black businesses that were
burned down
so that's actually racist burning down
black businesses
i just don't get it but really uh i have
a lot to figure out today because i
didn't know i was a white supremacist so
yeah you know and you know it's a bad
day for me you know what's worse about
you being a white supremacist
you being a white supremacist is
cultural appropriation exactly
because you are like actually you are
taking it from the actual
white supremacists who've been working
so hard to be bigots exactly you know
what
and if uh uh uh if i had on a red hat
and i burned down a building please
believe me i'm going to jail
yes please believe me i'm going to
prison okay
by the way if you weren't wearing a red
hat you'd probably get all three
exactly you needed to burn down that car
you know what i might burn some stuff
down tonight yeah yeah
but what's next are they going to
abolish the fire department yeah
evidently the fire evidently
firefighters are all racists they are
they are against arson they are so like
you know
it's their friends exactly yeah they
wear red hats too
good points racist my god everything's
racist cat cat are you going to join me
and boycott left-wing social justice
liturgical music
yeah i've been boycotting that for years
yes
i look i this is obviously an example of
cancel culture and
people have talked about that because it
is so obvious but it i think this is
also an example of the consequences of
our
current widespread binary view of
politics
which is something that i've experienced
for a while because i don't
have views that fit within to either
major party so if i espouse a view that
happens to be one that one of the major
parties has
people assume i agree with everything
else from that side and use it to attack
me
that's what happened to this guy he said
i don't like these people
burning down these buildings right and
so they assume that belief that he also
believed
uh that the protesters who were
protesting peacefully
were doing the wrong thing that he could
not support that movement even though
those things are in no way mutually
exclusive you could be against arson but
also support
uh the you know movement against racial
injustice and for police reform
um i've said for a while that we need
more independent thinking
uh i think that we need to just take
smaller steps now
and just say okay we need to be able to
recognize the possibility
that independent thinking might occur in
someone's head
we can just start there because this is
not something that has happened to this
guy it's happening all over the place
and it's dumb and it's not logically
correct and it creates
dumb narratives and dumb is bad you've
been watching a lot of the view
[Laughter]
wait do we have in his music to listen
to we don't know
maybe they got rid of him because he's a
bad musician you know that is a that
might be that that might that's the
unspeakable truth
this is the excuse hey you're a racist
but common sense is on fire common sense
is burning down right now
as we speak yeah that's true that's true
wait till you see the next topic
holy crap up next hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else